[Música]
boa tarde
o livro estava um ponto eu estava no
fundo mas não sentava no fundo porque eu
queria ser da turma do fundão você
estava no fundo porque eu tinha horror
de falar
ficava vermelha passava mal e eu tinha
uma amiguinha a emi quer uma oriental
que era tão tímido eu e ele dizia nosso
lado até que um dia vi uma professora de
português chamada lei que dá aula até
hoje lento na frente assim bom
a partir de semana que vem cada um de
vocês a virem aqui na frente apresentar
um tema ea gente vai chamar isso de aula
falada
foi como se dissesse fernanda você vai
morrer e você não consegue falar com
alguém aqui do meu lado
imagine lá na frente eo meu sobrenome
zerbini com z
então era a última da lista o que foi
pior porque eu fui vendo amigos meus que
falavam bem gaguejando que se não fossem
eles estão gaguejando imagens vão
conseguir falar tem álcool hoje que a
gente chama de bullying nos anos 80
também tinha só que não tinha sinal e
tinha uma leandrinho quer um loirinho de
olho azul do popular e sentava na minha
frente porque todo time do chama o
extrovertido né
ele sabe do poder que exerce ele sentava
lá na frente e atrás da nova vida com os
clássicos de boi roubava o meu lanche
trocava a minha prova lembra que estava
se inscrevendo ele trocava e falava com
o seu nome
tirava 23 por causa dele ele tinha um
canivete que eu não sei como ele
conseguiu que ele falava assim se você
contar para alguém eu mato você acredita
então meu maior medo da minha aula
falada não é o que acontecer cola falada
é que o alexandre a fazer oque eu sou
chata então assunto tem que ser muito
bom
e pensando sobre os assuntos e eu achei
uma revista uma matéria sobre
quiromancia eu vou falar disso uma coisa
diferente hoje
projetores na minha época cartolina
peguei uma cartolina verdinha claro fiz
o 3d da época que ela pegasse a faquinha
com grafite esfumaça que está acordando
está falando da idade
[Música]
todo dia eu sonhava em ser revista e
observa até que chegou o dia não dormi à
noite chegando a escola colocou uma
cartolina nem lei aqui do lado
vamos começar como essa eu vou pode
começar a fernanda quando ela pode
começar eu mirei um ponto assim e
dissipar efa que não fazia lá entrou nó
quando eu vejo uma mão levantada quem é
alexandre você não está entendendo que
se está falando é uma direita à esquerda
que lê e eu sabia que a direita quando
eu vejo o alexandre olhando pra mão e
olhando o cartaz
pensei uau não morri
não que tenha sido uma grande
apresentação mas ali eu percebi que
todas as pessoas podiam falar realmente
público que a gente podia desenvolver
que é uma habilidade e ali eu me
apaixonei pela comunicação que eu acabei
de fazer história
hoje nós ouvimos histórias porque a
gente gosta de contar nossas histórias
de ouvir histórias de ler histórias de
assistir a histórias porque somos
histórias e storytelling ele é um slow
motion no mundo de velocidade no mundo
de ninguém tem tempo em que tem pra
conversar mas pra ouvir uma história a
gente tem ea história gruda quando a
gente pensa no storytelling elementos
que a gente tem que pensar de um bom
histórico tele e eu gosto de pensar num
ótimo contador de história chesp e eu
quero trazer para vocês aqui hoje três
peças de shakespeare que pra mim dão
dicas de como criar uma boa história
a primeira peça a tempestade
um bom histórico nem precisa de conflito
obstáculo de trevas tempestade se alguém
me perguntar assim
depois desse evento vai financiar e aí
como foi o ted aetate foi incrível foi
maravilhoso tudo certo as pessoas
adoraram ninguém mas como foi o ted nem
te conto uma história pra contar uma boa
história tem tempestade tem problema ou
como eu gosto de chamar abacaxi
eu tive um professor de dramaturgia
muito bom tem que ele diz o seguinte
joão queria ir ao cinema maria que o
cinema é a melhor opção
joão querido do cinema maria que é o
teatro joão quer viajar maria quer ficar
em casa
o choque é comprar um barco passar um
ano foto maria que tem família filhos um
joão comprou um barco maria tá grávida
tem história
quanto mais impôs cadu mais abacaxi
tiver foi grande
o abacaxi lá de tudo melhor
aliás itu com ótima história até então a
gente pensar na sua história a gente tem
que pensar primeiro nessa tempestade
nesse problema porque porque na
tempestade sim é no momento mais sombrio
que a personagem encontra luz é hora que
a gente se transforma em muitas cenas de
filmes que a pessoa pode estar assim
acabar tá no fundo do poço que ela faz
ela falou dá pra piorar que acontece no
shopping
então a chuva tempestade é um símbolo
ótimo de conflito problema
uma segunda peça em e um segundo
elemento de boston e tele sonho de uma
noite de verão
as personagens precisam de sonhos de
desejos o que vai impulsionar ela pra
frente
vocês têm sonhos aqui e tem um momento
da peça que se diz assim há quem diga
que todas as noites são feitas de sonhos
mas há também quem garanta que nem todas
só de verão
no fundo isso pouco importa o que
importa mesmo são as noites em si são os
sonhos sonhos que o homem sonha sempre
em todos os lugares em todas as épocas
do ano dormindo ou acordado então uma
boa personagem precisa ter sonho e um
grande sonho é o que vai mover ela e uma
terceira peça aqui não poderia faltar um
bom histórico telem precisa do momento
se o p or not to be that is the question
a gente precisa do momento de ser ou não
ser eis a questão porque vivemos isso
todos os dias
chocolate café açúcar ou adoçante pinto
o cabelo de ruivo de olho mas tem
escolhas que são fáceis e tem escolhas
que são difíceis
fala não falo peço não peço aceito não
aceito vou ou não vou porque é difícil
porque a gente não sabe qual é o
resultado
se a gente soubesse seria fácil então se
a gente pensar existe uma dança no
storytelling
isso é uma tempestade que a personagem
tem que enfrentar que é difícil mas
existe o sonho que impulsiona nela pra
frente quase como uma mola e se a gente
pensar nessa tempestade nesse sonho
acontece o ser ou não ser
o tempo todo seja de pensão nesses
elementos de ser ou não ser de escolha
que é muito difícil de fazer
quem ajuda uma personagem uma
protagonista que está no meio dessa
tempestade a passar por ela são os
coadjuvantes
a gente fala muito do protagonista mas
hoje eu quero falar do coadjuvante e o
coadjuvante é um maravilhoso
guarda-chuva na sua vida
o quadro ante a quem ajuda a
protagonista passar por isso a ajuda a
fazer escolhas ajuda ela não esquecer
seus sonhos e eu quero trazer pra vocês
quatro tipos de coadjuvantes e que
talvez o provavelmente vocês vão lembrar
deles na sua vida agora é pensar no
código vant mais forte que existe
família pai mãe irmãos um bom
coadjuvante ele tem uma boa frase a
gente tem que pensar no código anti uma
boa frase que vai ajudar o protagonista
porque não existem pequenos papéis e sim
pequenos atores
minha mãe disse isso quando estudava
teatro e quando eu pegava o papel
principal falava mãe não tem talento tem
talento e minha mãe de amy fala fernanda
não existem pequenos papéis e sim
pequenos atores e secou
há muito tempo assim como meu pai um dia
passando a quinta ea tuba
ele estava me contando uma história que
tem relação com a cidade e no final ele
falou assim fernanda por isso minha
filha
siga o seu instinto
eu nunca mais esqueci isso no momento de
escolha difícil eu sigo no extinto pai e
mãe são coadjuvantes que estão essas
boas frases pra gente
e vocês devem ter essas frases com vocês
porque quando eles forem é o que vai
ficar
eles vão ecoar aqui existe um outro tipo
de coadjuvante que leve que é divertido
são os amigos e os amigos finca com você
da chuva em frente à tempestade junto
abrir um vinho bebe um vinho com você no
meio dessa tempestade faz graça quando
você tá rindo do meio dessa tempestade
você a dança comigo
os amigos são fundamentais porque eles
dão leveza e é um coadjuvante que a
gente não consegue passar pela vida sem
eles porque eles não exatamente esse
riso diante da tempestade
existe um outro existe um coadjuvante
que é o coadjuvante do conhecimento são
os mestres são os nossos professores
nós entramos em cursos e estudamos
encontrar essas pessoas que tenham
conhecimento e nos motivam a mudança
então eles transmitem isso ea gente tem
sempre eterna gratidão mas tem um tipo
de coadjuvante que eu adoro que é o
estranho que entra na sua vida do acaso
e que faz de si acaso algo incrível
lembra o momento da minha vida que eu
estava estudando de manhã fazendo curso
para o trabalho e estudando a noite
teatro e foi um momento que eu tive um
problema nos ligamentos do joelho andava
com uma muleta e te aquele momento bem
de tempestade e lembro que um dia o
acordo com conjuntivite então tava lá
dava como muleta e eu amarrar uma
sacolinha na muleta que tinha o dinheiro
para o táxi e eu estudava de manhã a
república tinha aqui pra vergueiro antes
de profundidade para trocar de roupa
tanto eu sei do curso tão a quando abri
a sacolinha
não acho o dinheiro meu coração está
naquele momento que vem a gota d'água
para mim foi aquelas sacolinhas em dia
eu comecei já a chorar como se não
houvesse amanhã como você não vai ser
ninguém naquela praça da república
quando o homem porque bom e menina que
você tá chorando
wang que eu vou sair daqui pública
entretanto oito melhor eu tenho que o
bagulho quando eu falei eu vou manter o
peso e local onde vai encontrar o homem
guerreiro que tem vai km2 que ir voltar
quando se precisa treinar eu podia ver o
poder que é isso aí foi que o taxista
assim ela precisa prover gay lá no
brutal quanto dessa corrida vai disputar
dois reais
quando eu olho né conjuntivite
quando eu vejo ele está lá pedindo
dinheiro pra mim
em pouco tempo ele vem com os doze reais
lá e que ele fazia storytelling
ele fazia isso naturalmente a menina lá
que ela chorando a ela precisa pagar até
uma sacolinha ela perdeu dinheiro tanto
quer
e aí quando eu entrei num táxi com as
boletas tal a família e mostrando como
eu vou te devolver o dinheiro ele falou
você vai me agradecer de outra maneira
uma boa frase bom na vida passa estou eu
no metrô lá onde espera aí
quando olha para o lado e vejo uma
menina chorando como se não houvesse
amanhã
como se não houvesse mais quem lá ele
nossa deve ter brigado com a namorada
estranha ele sabe
lembrei do meu pai consegui tudo bem
pergunta idiota porque o banco central
começou a conversar eu falei que foi
ótima e danos e falar em quanto foi
nossa eu também leio trabalho com isso
porque eu acredito nisso que qualquer um
pode falar e comecei a bater papo com
ela tal então ele explicou que ela não
agüentava mais aquilo que já se passaram
muitos anos e ela não conseguia ter
amigos não consegue namorar tanto só que
passou um tempo a gente conversando
ela estava melhor ela falou assim a
fernando olha que bom que você veio
conversar comigo
porque eu ia fazer uma besteira e
naquela hora simples igual é coadjuvante
totalmente porque naquela hora eu pensei
eu
como a gente tem esse poder de ver
histórias na nossa frente e mudá las
quem conversei com ela terminou vá tudo
bem melhor só vai prometer uma coisa
você vai pra casa tomar um banho tomar
um chá dormir e sonhar e sonha bem
gostoso ver com coisas legais não pode
deixar tal bola estava entrando
tranquilo como que eu vou te agradecer
lembrei na hora do táxi na hora que foi
o cara que eu nunca consegui agradecer
me colocou num táxi e eu coloquei ela
não traem e é isso que um coadjuvante
faz ele só lembra o caminho que o
protagonista tem que correr a passar por
essa tempestade quando a gente pensa no
papel de coadjuvante e hoje eu quero
trazer muita tona
nada seria nada daria certo sem um bom
coadjuvante na história interna código
vant ele ajuda exatamente a gente passar
por essas tempestades e quando a gente
pensa o que tem o seu término
esta tempestade tem os nossos medos a
maior tempestade que existe a interna
então eu quero encerrar hoje fala no
seguinte
se vocês colocarem todas essas
imperfeições as nossas imperfeições
contadas em histórias
a gente pode criar uma perfeita conexão
muito obrigado e viveu uma história
[Aplausos]